well hello there my inbox just got
bombarded because Conan O'Brien logged
his doctor's visit so I thought I'd
watch it and react to it perhaps even a
good learning opportunity let's get
started
[Music]
anyone noticed yet today that my voice
sounds a little different is it sound a
little different to you little sexier a
little lower thanks a lot there's a
reason for that I haven't actually felt
well today
you bastards yeah we're talking about my
physical health and little does Kona
know his physical health is intimately
tied in with his mental health so if
he's not performing well physically it
could make him quite upset which can
lead to feelings of worry anxiety even
depression in some cases I just have I
don't some kind of virus or something
and I last night I was up all night
really sore throat I woke up today achy
just don't feel well come to work as the
show must go on what it sounds like that
he's describing could be either a viral
illness or could be bacterial illness
the fact that he's saying body aches and
sore throat he's putting all of these
systems together sounds like I'm leaning
towards viral but it's hard to know from
his limited description here the one
thing I will tell you that some of the
most painful sore throats happen as a
result of a viral illness not strep
throat so don't jump to concluding that
because your throat is really sore it
must mean you have strep throat actually
it's not that the case it's actually the
other way a lot of nyquil and woke up
with my felt better sort of the guy I
was with oh he just threw in one of
those didn't he please don't take a lot
of nyquil folks cuz nyquil is actually a
combination medicine it has what is the
equivalent of benadryl in it and tylenol
so it not only is a pain reliever but it
also puts you to sleep however better
drill or nyquil for that matter if you
take it and you don't go to sleep and
you stay up it's actually worse for you
in terms of concentration and ability to
perform tasks than alcohol there's
actually been a study done that tested
people who were under the influence of
alcohol in comparison to those who took
benadryl and those who took benadryl
were worse drivers than the alcohol
group is that crazy do you feel
comfortable talking to
about the stomach stuff that was going
on like was it nausea diarrhea like what
was uh what was that symptom you really
want me to talk about diarrhea in
television when we're seeing the
symptoms of an upper respiratory
infection starts spreading into the GI
tract what that points my mind to is to
a specific virus called adenovirus now
this is one that affects both upper
respiratory and GI tract and can cause
diarrhea in fact diarrhea and upper
respiratory symptoms point you to the
direction of thinking that this could be
caused by a virus because if you have
just an infection of bacteria in your
throat it's very unlikely that it's
going to start spreading into the GI
system right away so the fact that he's
having multiple system involvement here
really makes me lean towards the idea
that this is a virus do you ever find
yourself talking to patients and they
mention it that they've had diarrhea and
you start laughing that's sad when all
the joy goes out of your life I don't
think I've ever laughed when a patient
tells me diarrhea unless they describe
it in a funny way where they're trying
to be funny then we can share laughs I
try and do some kind of humor with it
like are you just constantly running are
you basically having diarrhea in your
pants so the patients and I both get a
good laugh and they understand that this
is very disarming functions as a way to
break down this barrier that often
exists between patients and doctors
where we have to be very strict and very
proper we can have a good time we can
laugh if this somehow could all end with
you saying well you're an amazing male
specimen and I had that on camera that
would be great but that's you decide an
amazing male specimen can you imagine if
like a doctor does a prostate exam and
then afterwards he's like you're an
amazing male specimen I think that would
be really weird feedback to get we're
trained not to use weird language like
that during our practicals like for
example if I'm listening to someone's
heart I'm looking inside their ears I'm
doing a vaginal exam
I'm always trained to say everything
looks normal or everything sounds normal
instead of saying good but when you say
everything looks normal that's less
provocative there's no real wrong way to
take normal let's start with taking your
temperature what they have the Scrubs
poster right there
that's it even hanging crooked for
effect that's awesome
he looks those miserable
right on 75 you're actually cold a lot
of wax in there I wonder if he's wincing
because she's putting it in deep or he's
just trying to be funny with it cuz
generally that procedure shouldn't be
that uncomfortable you can get a good
view of the tympanic membrane or the
eardrum without pushing too far and
causing discomfort it's actually one of
the mistakes that a lot of my medical
students make that to tell them like why
are you pushing in so deep think about
how uncomfortable that feels to the
patient and when they realize that sweet
spot then you can do it consistently
over and over again without causing
discomfort to a patient the best thing
you can do when a doctor is trying to
look into the back of your throat keep
your tongue out the whole time and
consistently say the sound ah ah the
reason why we say say ah is because it
lifts your palate and when it lifts your
palate we have a really good view of the
back of your throat I'll say to my
patients like open up they'll open their
mouth no sticks or tongue out I'll say
say ah and they'll go ah hey I didn't
get any view of anything what are you
feeling they're feeling first of all in
lymph nodes glands may be tender yeah if
they were swollen and enlarged that
would be indicative of a form of
infection or inflammation glands do get
swollen during that time but they should
return back to normal after a period of
time if your glands don't return to
normal they stay swollen that's a reason
to go see your doctor there's a tattoo
there it says REO Speedwagon rules 78
one of the most important things that
you want to tell patients when you're
listening to their lungs using a
stethoscope is to make sure they take
deep breaths through their mouth this is
the largest airway there's no mucus in
there I like the nose where it's a
smaller area where there's mucus in
there and you can get upper airway
sounds like that sound gets transmitted
into your lungs and you'll hear it and
you won't be able to decipher is that
coming from the nose or from the lungs I
want as much medication as I could
possibly have really a lot of my
patients come in asking for medications
it's a common misconception that if you
have a virus or if you have a strep
throat that unless you get antibiotics
you're not going to get
this is not the case if you're otherwise
healthy you're always gonna get better
in fact if you have strep throat for
which we give antibiotics for we are
only shortening the course of shrimp
throat illness by 16 hours it normally
lasts seven to eight days and we're
saving you 16 hours of symptoms by
giving you the antibiotic the antibiotic
is now for your symptoms ladies and
gentlemen the antibiotic is there
strictly to prevent the complications of
strep throat you know sometimes you hear
about like it was a cool tylenol that
they only sell in Sweden it has I've had
patients say that they heard about some
cool supplement that promises to shorten
the duration of a cold if they take mega
doses I know there's no magic fix
there's no magic vitamin it's about
getting the proper rest hydration
getting the right amount of calories in
and allowing your body to do its job you
haven't said anything for a while the
reason why we don't say anything for a
while is because there's a few areas we
have to listen to we have to listen to
on the right side of your chest then we
have to move over to the left side of
your chest and there's four places that
we listen to on the left side of the
chest so unless we do all this we have
to take a few seconds to actually hear
the rhythm make sure we don't hear a
murmur because that's what we're
listening to and to make sure that the
rate is normal not only in terms of how
fast it's beating but the rhythm as well
a harpy it should be baboom baboom
baboom it should keep a proper rhythm if
all of a sudden you're getting boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom that
could be a sign of atrial fibrillation
which is its own cardiac arrhythmia and
all sorts of other issues in which case
we would then want to get extra testing
like an EKG perhaps an echocardiogram
depending on what we're suspecting but
the biggest reason we listen to is for
murmurs when you have something wrong
with the valves of your heart or
actually the chambers of your heart we
hear turbulent flow meaning that if you
ever hear fluid move through a pipe and
the pipe is nice and clear you're not
gonna hear anything it's silent but if
something all of a sudden gets in the
way and the water has to move around it
that turbulence creates a sound that's
what we're listening to
your chest do you have much of our
prolapse or anything
what's the problems it's a one of the
valves in the hearts just a little bit
floppy I just came here to shoot me son
Charlie I came here to shoot like a
silly little I've got a cold and we're
gonna just screw around and you're
selling something real yeah but it's
nothing you don't have a murmur anything
so my chill values talking about here is
technically like floppy heart valves
well we're specifically talking about
the left side of the heart in between
the lower portion which is the left
ventricle and the left atrium there's
something known as the mitral valve and
it's too little leaflets and sometimes
they do get floppy and they don't sit
evenly with each other and actually
prolapse to the left atrium and when
that happens is you could have a little
bit of leakage of blood that goes into
the left atrium when it's not supposed
to but most of the time patients are
asymptomatic meaning they don't even
know they have it and we just find it
kind of on a routine physical exam and
no treatment is needed that's why she
wasn't so worried about it I have a
floppy heart
a lot of the inner rage I'm Irish
Catholic stock right I'm worried we
don't do well in the long run we're not
people that live a long time I think
it's really important to talk about
someone's mental state because if
they're not in a healthy mental state
they're gonna take longer to recover
from their symptoms they're gonna have
worse symptoms on average so I like to
get that in the open and see if there's
anything we can offer this patient limb
fatigue questions okay what do you think
I'm I'm pretty good male yeah really
fantastic I think maybe in replace male
specimen you think maybe I'm a male
specimen now this is the sort of wimpy
sudafed cuz we can't really get the real
sudafed anymore because of the crystal
meth problem so i can't make crystal
meth out of this Conan O'Brien is a
fantastic male specimen are you got her
to say it oh good Conan was awesome for
showing this showing his medical visit
joking about it talking about his
symptoms this is how we make changes in
the medical community by opening it up
by being more transparent by showing
doctors have a sense of humor I have two
videos that you have to watch first is
right here untold stories of the ER this
one is fun
and then the one that is really unique
is this woman who can smell Parkinson's
disease yeah she can actually smell it
click on one of these bad boys
now and stay happy and healthy
[Music]